♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK TWO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT,"
TONIGHT IN TOKYO.
BACK IN AMERICA, BUT, IT MIGHT
DETERMINE WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
NEXT PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
A GOOGLE WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS COME
FORWARD TO DISCUSS THE MIKE
DESCRIBED HIS' PLANS TO REMAKE
THE LANDSCAPE.
THAT WILL SHAPE WHAT AMERICANS
SEE ONLINE AND YOU BETTER TAKE
IT SERIOUSLY.
>> IS THAT DOG WHISTLE.
IT DOES NOT MEAN WHAT YOU THINK
THAT IT MEANS AND YOU HAVE TO
APPLY DOUBLETHINK IN ORDER TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY ARE REALLY
SAYING.
WHAT THEY ARE REALLY SAYING
ABOUT FAIRNESS IS THEY HAVE TO
MANIPULATE THEIR SEARCH RESULTS.
THEY HAVE TO RE-BIAS THEIR
ALGORITHMS, SO THEY CAN GET
THEIR AGENDA ACROSS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE
DEFINITION OF PROPAGANDA,
PERPETUATED BY THE SINGLE MOST
POWERFUL COMPANY OF THE WORLD.
JAMES DORAN WAS FIRED FROM
GOOGLE FOR HIS POLITICAL VIEWS,
AND THEY CAME ON THIS SHOW.
>> THERE ARE DEFINITELY SOME
POLITICAL BIASES WITHIN GOOGLE
THAT I WAS TRYING TO SHED LIGHT
ON IN A DOCUMENT AND THAT THEY
AFFECT MANY PARTS OF THE
BUSINESS AND FOR EXAMPLE, WHO
THEY DO BUSINESS WITH AND WHAT
TYPE OF CONTENT THEY CREATE.
I THINK THOSE POLITICAL BIASES
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT JUST
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
HIDDEN CAMERA FOOTAGE OBTAINED
BY PROJECT VERITAS SHOWS
CONVERSATIONS WITH JEN DENY, OR
GOOGLE TITLE IS AHEAD OF
RESPONSIVE INNOVATIONS.
IF 2016 HAVE BEEN AGAIN, WHAT
THE OUTCOME BE DIFFERENT?
PEOPLE ARE NOT PUTTING THAT LINE
IN THE SAND.
WE ARE A BIG COMPANY AND WE ARE
GOING TO SAY IT.
IN OTHER WORDS WE WILL TRY TO
AFFECT THE OUTCOME OF THE 2,020
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
SO THAT GOES ON TO BLAST
ELIZABETH WARREN'S PROPOSAL TO
BREAK GOOGLE UP INTO TWO
COMPANIES.
THEY WILL BE CHARGED WITH
PREVENTING THE NEXT TRUMP
SITUATION.
IT'S LIKE, A SMALL COMPANY
CANNOT DO THAT.
SO USING A COMPANY'S DOMINANCE
ON THE INTERNET TO SWAY THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION, THAT'S
THE PLAN.
THERE SHOULD BE A TERM FOR WHAT
SHE IS DESCRIBING.
IT'S A TERM THAT YOU'VE HEARD
CONSTANTLY FROM TALKING HEADS ON
TELEVISION FOR MORE THAN TWO
YEARS.
IT'S CALLED HACKING AN ELECTION.
GOOGLE WANTS TO HACK AN ELECTIO
ELECTION, AND, ALL THE OTHER
PROPAGANDA'S.
HACKING AN ELECTION IS VERY BAD.
AND YET, IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
THE WASHINGTON ESTABLISHMENT HAS
SAID THEY WANT TO PREVENT
ELECTION INTERFERENCE BUT OF
COURSE, THAT'S A LIE.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
CONTROL THE ELECTIONS AND THAT
IS THE ONLY GOAL.
THEY ARE NOT ATTACKING THE REAL
SOURCE OF ELECTION OF
INTERFERENCE WHICH IS
SILICON VALLEY.
NO SERIOUS PERSON DOUBTS THAT.
BUT THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF OUR
COUNTRY DON'T CARE ABOUT ANYONE,
ANY OF THAT.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU WANT TO FIND
THAT VIDEO, YOU CAN ACCESS IT ON
YOUTUBE.
AND GOOGLE TOOK IT DOWN.
AND THEY WILL ACCUSE YOU, THEY
PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE BANNING ANY
DNC TIME.
MEANWHILE, REVELRY, BANNED ALL
EXPLICIT SUPPORT FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
MOST REPUBLICANS HAVEN'T
RESPONDED TO IT.
AS SOON THE 2016 ELECTION IS
OVER, THE PRESIDENT AND TECH
PLOTTED IN 2,020.
AND THE REPUBLICANS WERE IN
CHARGE OF THE CONGRESS.
THEY SAT MOTIONLESS AND HAVE
DONE NOTHING.
THE ONLY REPUBLICAN WHO SEEMS
EVEN INTERESTED AT ALL IN THE
SUBJECT IN TECH AT ALL IS JOSH
HAWLEY.
AND THAT IS INVALUABLE
REGULATORY EVIDENCE.
SUCCESSFUL POLITICAL PARTIES
LOOK OUT FOR THEIR SUPPORTERS
AND THE PUBLIC AT LARGE AND
PROTECT THEM FROM HARM.
REPUBLICANS MEANWHILE ARE
SITTING IN A STUPEFIED FOG OF
LIBERTARIANISM, DOING NOTHING.